people are not willing to concede that
intelligent people of goodwill
can be on the other side of them from an
issue it's very easy to think of a kind
of faceless abstraction of conservatives
or liberals and they're all terrible
people
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sundays special we are
joined today by Ramesh Ponnuru he's
visiting fellow at the American
Enterprise Institute he's senior editor
at National Review he's an opinion
columnist for Bloomberg I can't wait to
get started with the conversation but
first you know if you look at the
economy right now what you'll notice is
that central banks are taking a heavy
toll on the economy last week China
devalued its currency and markets tanked
one consequence was that Bitcoin prices
rose it's time to consider including
some crypto in your portfolio now I know
that crypto sounds kind of scary but
what crypto really is is it is a limited
commodity like something like gold it's
kind of like digital gold it's protected
by blockchain they're not creating any
more of it as protected from hacking it
is a resource that can't be manipulated
by central governments if you're
interested in getting into looking at
crypto you should be taking a look at
étoile it is smart crypto trading you
can access the world's best crypto
currencies they have 15 different crypto
currencies available and you can try
before you trade with a virtual
portfolio with a hundred thousand dollar
budget so you can actually try it out
and see how you like it you never miss a
trading trend with chart and pricing
alerts so you're learning how to trade
crypto in real time sign up today at
eToro comm slash Shapiro that's ETO our
o calm slash Shapiro if you're fearful
of government's manipulating currencies
if you're worried about the vacillation
of the markets maybe you should be
looking at something like crypto and the
best way to do that try it out over at
eToro comm slash up hero and they give
you the opportunity again to try it out
before you're even spending any of your
own money go check them out at eToro
comm slash capiro that is ET o ro comm
slash Shapiro eToro comm slash up here o
Rometsch thanks so much for stopping by
you're welcome or it's Dinesh Ramesh
yeah you're telling you Anderson comes a
common confusion actually Anderson
Cooper's among many illustrious people
who have made that mistake so and I'm so
much better-looking too so it's I mean
I've met Dinesh and I must agree it must
agree so let's start the spicy stuff
your perspective on on President Trump
so you've talked before about how you
think the president Trump has affected
the Republican Party and the
perspectives of Americans going forward
on politics do you think that he is a
net benefit or a net negative for
conservatism and conservatives well I
mean I think you'd have to say that he's
accomplished a lot that conservatives
want so he got two appointees to the
Supreme Court who are pretty
conservative at
justice Gorsuch has been a more solid
conservative and originalist than
justice Cavanaugh so far has shown
himself to be we got a I think a tax
reform that is on balance pretty good we
just we've seen a lot of deregulation
and so I think a lot of good things have
happened I think that there's a lot that
is to coin a word deplorable in the
president's conduct and and the way he
fills the role of the presidency but the
thing that really strikes me about Trump
is the extent to which it often seems
that the goal of his presidency is to
make himself the center of every
conversation in America and to a
surprising degree he succeeded in that
ambition and so what I think is a
problem for conservatism whether you're
an anti-trump conservative or a pro
Trump conservative or somewhere in
between
all thought has been sort of paralyzed
and everything just gets sucked into a
conversation about the president's
personality I mean there's no question
that that's true in terms of general
politics and my great worry about
President Trump from before he's elected
and certainly during his term has been
maybe political but he's been much more
conservative than I thought he would be
it's really been about the poisoning of
the well particularly with young people
in America and there seems to be a
certain level of Sanguinetti that has
that has arisen among a lot of
conservatives that because he bucked the
odds and won in 2016 that Republicans
are gonna win from here on out despite
the fact that 2018 one very poorly for
conservatives and Republicans there's
this sort of feeling that Trump is the
master of a wing of American politics
that nobody knows about that's unbel
that's sort of out there in the ether
and that he's gonna be able to draw from
that going forward and transform the
country along those lines what's your
assessment of what 2016 was actually
about and durability of the Trump
coalition going forward so I think you
have to separate the primaries and the
general election both of them very
interesting stories I think in the
primary you had a couple of things going
on you had the fact that the Republican
Party elites had tried to foist on the
party a consensus on immigration that
Republican voters didn't share and he
was the most visible opponent of that so
something like 7 percent of
chickens in a poll around that time
wanted more immigration and 15 of 16
Republican presidential candidates
wanted more immigration and Trump was
the sixteenth the one who said no to
that and was really advertising in an
unmistakable way that he would do what
it takes that he would be tough in a way
that previous people had only talked
about being tough on illegal immigration
that's one part of it another part he
had a kind of Republicans tend to prefer
the executive personality and there were
a number of Governors on the stage with
Trump but for various reasons there was
a diffidence or in Chris Christie's case
that kind of impulsiveness and glandular
t @k six cases a sort of flakiness and I
think the Trump actually was in a way
the most sort of traditional executive
figure on the stage and then finally
there was the fact that there was an
existing Republican sort of formula that
had been inherited from Reagan and no
longer spoke to Republican primary
voters and you know some of them
actually liked Trump's heterodox seized
on things like trade and entitlements
some of them didn't necessarily like
those things but they weren't they
weren't deal-breakers for them in the
way that some people thought they would
write Club for Growth around all these
ads saying he hasn't been with us on
this and he hasn't been with us on that
and then basically didn't register with
people so you had all that up and then
the fact that CNN covered him like it
was a missing plane he gets the
nomination in the general election I
think a lot of what he had going for him
was his opponent Hillary Clinton turns
out to have been a really terrible
candidate partly because conservatives
had spent 30 years working with her to
define her as unacceptable to a lot of
Americans and so you end up with two
candidates who 60% of the public you
have overlapping majorities of 60% the
public think they're unsuited for the
office they're unacceptable and the
people who thought they were both
unacceptable broke heavily for the
Challenger which brings us to another
point which I think gets underrated
which is it's very hard to hold on to
the presidency after two terms there was
going to be a time
change sentiments regardless of who the
party's nominated and that benefited
Trump I want to go back to a point that
you made about the breakdown in sort of
the Reagan coalition so there have been
this conventional wisdom that the
Republican Party was built around the
three-legged stool the fame three-legged
stool the social conservatives the
hawkish foreign policy acolytes and the
small government libertarians and that
you took sort of a small government view
a big defense view and a socially
conservative view and that was going to
be where the party was at and it seems
like there's been a lot of rethinking
about each one of those legs of the
stool and it seems as though President
Trump and his election have really
uncovered a real can of worms because
it's unclear how the coalition actually
operates now there are a lot of
libertarians in the coalition who are
not super socially conservative right
there there are a lot of people who are
or not small government conservatives
that the Tucker Carlson wing of the
party there are a lot of folks who are
now isolationist on foreign policy that
sort of Rand Paul wing of the party how
do you think the party breaks down do
you think that there is even a unified
program for the Republican Party that
isn't just the left is terrible right
well that's a it's a big set of
questions I would say president Trump
whether it's cunning or intelligence has
a really solid understanding of what the
red lines in Republican Party politics
are so there were some issues a lot of
issues where he flipped and when we talk
about how Trump is changed the
Republican Party we shouldn't forget the
Republican Party's also changed Trump
and changed him quite a bit he's not you
know the liberal that he was on most
issues back you know 15 20 years ago he
understood that he had to be pro-life he
understood I think that he had to be
pro-gun that he couldn't be for tax
increases now there are some other
issues where it turns out Republican
voters don't have strong attachments to
the old conservative orthodoxy
entitlements trade NATO all of those
things are in that basket of issues and
so I think he's he's first of all those
of the issues that he cares about the
most where he's hetero Doc's but he also
understood that he had Running Room on
those issues right now hating the left
is the glue of the Republican Party but
it's also true that hating the right is
the glue of the Democratic Party we have
negative polarization we're what holds
both party coalition's together
is less any policy objective or
philosophical principle than enmity
toward the other side and I think that
helps to account for a lot of the
sourness of American politics right now
and then you add in the fact that both
of these coalition's basically think
they're already a majority of the
country and if the other side wins
anything it's somehow illegitimate you
know it's people on our side it's the
deep state or it's the media people on
their side it's it's the Koch brothers
it's dark money it's Russian
interference and you know this is the
this is the perfect recipe for the era
of bad feelings that we are now living
in politically so looking back
historically now when do you think this
era of bad feelings started so I know
that there's there's a lot of talk about
you know it was born with Trump this
seems to be the media's line that
President Trump is not a symptom of the
era of bad feelings he's the initiator
of the era of bad feelings from from my
point of view this obviously was present
going all the way back to George W Bush
and Bush Hitler in the and the war in
Iraq
but you know there are other folks who
have argued that this really the seeds
of it were were driven by the fall of
the Soviet Union that in the absence of
some sort of existential threat from
abroad that Americans were bound to turn
our guns on each other politically
speaking and polarize along those lines
where do you think this started and why
is it gotten so bad
started in the Garden of Eden no I do
think that there was an element of truth
that that there was there were
pre-existing tendencies and trends that
Trump then accelerated and partly it's
just the the polarization of American
politics has to do with the realignment
of the Republican Party into being an
ideologically conservative party in a
way that it wasn't and that led to the
Democratic Party becoming a more
ideological Liberal Party and over time
this process fed on itself where the
Democratic Party becomes more liberal
than conservatives leave it and they are
not there anymore to restrain the
Democrats and there are no longer as
many conservative Democrats in the house
to restrain you know speaker Pelosi as
there used to be and this the same thing
happened on the Republican side I do
think one other big factor in this was
the nationalization of the social issues
once and I think the
there is row v Wade where you have one
side of this incredibly contentious
issue winning through judicial Fiat and
then every that becoming a sort of
dominant issue in national politics in a
way that it didn't have to be you could
have had a system where you know you
could be a pro-choice Republican in
California or a pro-life democrat in
Alabama and have a thriving national
career that used to be true but as our
politics became nationalized around that
issue it became less and less possible
for it to happen I mean I think that
that that's a great point about the
nationalization of the issues and it
does feel like you know when we talk
about the anti left sentiment inside the
conservative movement if you have to put
your finger on it it does feel like that
is driven almost entirely by culture and
social issues it feels like that all the
talk about the dispossessed workers in
the Midwest who had suddenly turn to
Trump when I talked to folks in the
Midwest their votes seem to be less
driven by Trump is going to redo the
trade deals with China and Mexico and
much more to do with the coasts hate us
and want to destroy our churches and
they want to wreck our communities and
they look down our nose at us and think
we're bitter clingers that there's
something a lot more passionate about
support for Trump than merely they sort
of like his economic program if they
like tariffs they could have had Bernie
Sanders too who's also pledged terrorism
I mean if you think about it in 2008
Obama you know in addition to pretending
to be against same-sex marriage he's
he's courting Rick Warren he's making
sort of moderate noises on abortion but
I think between 2012 and 2016 in
particular Democrats really bought this
idea that they're a coalition of the
ascendant all of their demographic
groups are expanding and the Republican
groups are declining we don't need to
pay attention to white working-class
voters anymore and the thing is people
get the message that you are writing
them off the exit poll thing that I
always harp on that nobody else has
noticed if you look at Wisconsin and
Pennsylvania and Michigan look at white
working-class voters white Catholic
voters white evangelical voters he's
overlapping constituencies Obama gets
crowned by Romney in each of those
groups in each of those states in 2012
but Hillary Clinton just got absolutely
crushed and the difference was enough to
swing all three of those states that is
that if she had just
held her losses to where they were in
2012 you know there would have been
enough votes that you'd have had a you
know more than 77 thousand votes
necessary to win all three of those
states in the electoral college I mean
this is one of the the points that I
think the media is seem to keep missing
when they talk about racism driving the
Republican Party there there is racism
in the Republican Party there's
intersectional racism in the Democratic
Party too but the the idea that because
white voters started to think of
themselves more as a voting bloc that
that is a response a racist response to
President Obama in particular it seems
to me a historical because it seems like
the the Democratic Party in the media
spent years suggesting that this
coalition of the ascendant was going to
leave behind white working-class voters
they're no longer relevant to our
politics and people in response said
well I'm not going to vote for you I'm
gonna vote for the other party at least
those people are not you yeah exactly
and it seems like a reactionary response
to the left not merely we don't like
Barack Obama because he's black and if
you look at the social science on racial
conservatism being associated with the
vote and being a good predictor of the
vote in 2016 we racial conservatism is a
turn of term of art and if you look at
it it's basically just conservatism
applied to race and these racially
conservative attitudes like the idea
that that people have a lot of agency
and can better their own lot and not
everything is the fault of
discrimination that is a view that is
shared by a lot of Hispanics and a lot
of blacks and it's it's really sort of
white progressives who are most
vociferous and the rejection of those
views I mean yeah that's exactly I look
at these studies and they start
characterizing views like people are
responsible for their actions as racist
and I'm just thinking to myself how is
that even remotely racist I mean that
that is just a normal run-of-the-mill
conservative view and more than
conservative view from any mainstream
Americans who are not conservative feel
that way and that sort of polarization
is getting worse now let's talk about
the Democratic Party because it's pretty
clear that I want to get back to the
Republican Party and where you think
that the the fragmenting tensions are
where you think the future of the
Republican Party is on get back to that
but the Democratic Party I think that
politically the Democrats have been the
driver of our politics since at least
2008 and that Barack Obama's election
was a realigning election in a lot of
ways that Barack
campaign in 2008 was not the Barack
Obama who governed for his presidency
they kind of hope he and changee and
were united not divided and no red
states no blue states Obama never showed
up in the Oval Office he campaign and
then he just went on vacation for eight
years and instead Barack Obama decided
to build the the coalition that you
talked about and that that alienated a
lot of people and that's led to a
Democratic Party so radical that they
can't even invoke President Obama in in
positive fashion anymore they're too
woke for Obama at this point which is
left Joe Biden in the lurch is the only
person standing there going hey remember
me it was okay when when Obama was
president what's your take on on the
direction of the Democratic Party so I
think one oddity of the Democratic Party
I think it's been moving left really
since the Clinton administration and
both victory and defeat since the
Clinton ministration has been
radicalizing for the Democrats so when
they win it encourages kind of
complacency about their leftism that you
know they believe that history is on
their side they're you know they're the
coalition of the ascendant they own the
future and then when they lose it just
causes them to radicalize out of
bitterness and rage and you know usually
when they lose it means they lose their
most moderate members in their house and
their Senate caucuses and the problem
with the kind of so they're they're
always prone to this thinking that
they've got the future locked because
they're progressives and that sort of
this idea that history has a direction
is just built into their worldview and
the problem they have is prematurity so
just as there's no reward in the stock
market for being right prematurely
appealing to the hypothetical voters of
the future is not a substitute for
getting the actual votes of people today
and you I think it's pretty clear that
that was a mistake they made in 2016 but
what's amazing to me is that they often
seem like they want to recapitulate that
mistake and really it's just it's so
similar to what they did in 2016 what
did they do in 2016 right they assume
that trump is unacceptable to the
electorate and therefore they they may
ask Republicans for their votes they may
say hey you can vote for me but they
won't make any kind of programmatic
compromise they won't do safe legal and
rare
the way they used to do on abortion they
won't say hey of course we are not going
to confiscate guns even those who aren't
actually for confiscation in general
they're not going out of their way to
say that they're not for confiscation in
the way that previous Democrats are or
you see me previous Democrats Democrats
were and so it seems to me the exact
same bet in a lot of ways that they made
in 2016 though maybe it'll work out this
time or maybe Biden who's a little bit
less in sync with that way of thinking
will get the nomination and run a
different kind of campaign but it does
seem to me to be an awfully risky choice
the Democrats are making it seems to me
politically that both parties are stuck
in this weird model where they think
that Barack Obama was the new normal
when Barack Obama was actually the
electoral outlier what I mean by that is
the Democrats seem to think that Barack
Obama completely reshift Adana of
American politics so far that the
coalition that he built is durable and
Andry winnable for every Democrat it's
not unique to Obama you can run an old
white woman and she's going to win
exactly the same coalition and even more
voters and it'll be just fine and on the
right I think that there was a response
to Obama that said okay his coalition is
durable we need something new and
something shocking to break up this
coalition and the truth is that in 2016
both Hillary and Trump performed kind of
like generic democrat and generic
Republican in other words Barack Obama
was the guy who had broken the dam
because he was Barack Obama and innately
talented politician who also had a great
level of skill and and an enormous
amounts of positive media coverage but
Hillary Clinton is not that and in the
absence of Barack Obama the the
assumptions of durability of that
coalition among Democrats is exaggerated
or or do you think that maybe they have
a point that as time goes on that
coalition actually is a sentence over
time well I would say that if you look
at and like we've sort of talked about
this online if you look at 20 on Votto
there is reason for Republicans and
conservatives to worry as the country
particularly gets browner and blacker
and less white and possibly less
religious there's some grave reasons for
concern but these demographic changes
they happen slowly it is still the case
that there are persuadable voters out
there who you know are gonna go maybe
this way or that way too
on the choices that are put in front of
them a lot of people saw what the change
in the elections of 2004 and 2008 and
just vastly over read them and
demographic change just doesn't happen
that rapidly now I do think that there
are some Republicans who spent sort of
the Republican strategist class spent
all the Obama years saying we all have
to move way left on immigration and all
these other things because of these
demographic changes and they were
overreacting but I think that there's
kind of this implicit sense now among
Republicans while all that was garbage
and we don't need to do anything and you
know in the long run the demographics
are real and they do have to be
accounted for so the second I want to
ask you a little bit more about the
demographics and I want to have you
expand on the on the brown or black or
comments so just for media matters
because we know of course that they will
come after anybody who mentions
demographic change and we'll talk about
that in just one second first I don't go
to the post office anymore that's not
because I don't like the services of the
post office the post office is great but
if I go there I have to schlep all my
stuff in my car I have to get in the car
I have to go there I may get a parking
ticket last time I was out the post
office I did get a parking ticket from
now on I'm using stamps calm and you
need stamps com2 it's one of the most
popular time-saving tools for small
businesses
stamps.com eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you money with
discounts you can't even get at the post
office
stamps com will bring you all the
amazing services of the US postal office
direct to your computer whether you're a
small office sending invoices or an
online seller shipping out products even
a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps comm can handle it
all with ease simply use your computer
to print official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just hand it to your mail
carrier or drop it in the mailbox it's
that simple with stamps calm you get
five cents off every first class stamp
up to 40% off Priority Mail stamps calm
is a no-brainer it saves you time it
saves you money
it's no wonder over 700,000 small
businesses already use stamps calm they
really do make life easier which is why
we use them here at sailing wire right
now my listeners get a special offer it
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale no long term
commitment just go to stamps com click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Shapiro that stamps
comm enter Shapiro okay so let's talk
about that line that you talked about
the country getting browner and black
are that being a problem for Republicans
so the left will say of course
a problem for Republicans because
they're racist and and that's the reason
why President Trump is trying to
restrict immigration is not because he
cares about the culture of the country
it's because he cares about the race of
the country so I just want to have you
clarify what exactly you mean by that so
that folks don't immediately accuse you
of being a white supremacist who wants a
white country as a white man yes as an
Orthodox Jew exactly I think that there
is a case for immigration policy changes
my own thought on that is mostly that
immigration has been a very successful
experience for our country and to help
it continue to be a successful
experience for our country we need to
have an immigration policy that is
conducive to immigrants assimilating to
our country and that doesn't mean that
there are no cultural differences that
no you can't keep some of the traits and
some of the traditions and heritage of
the place you came from but what I mean
is mostly that immigrants see themselves
that are seen by others as being full
participants in American life it seems
to me that that's probably going to be
more successful when you've got a
diverse flow of immigrants when you've
got a controlled flow and when it's a
relatively highly-skilled flow of
immigrants whether those are the exact
same thoughts that motivate President
Trump I am NOT going to speculate but
then there's also this political
question which regardless of what our
immigration policy is it just seems to
me that the demographic or the
Republican Party continues to be married
white Christians that was the
demographic core of the country but it
is a shrinking share of the population
and whatever immigration policy we have
it seems to me Republicans have to break
out of that box and and expand their
appeal to other kinds of voters or you
know it would also be nice and more
people got married I suppose but I think
there are different problems that
Republicans have with these with
different racial minorities but a lot of
it is related to not going out and
asking for the vote not being a
continuing presence in different
communities and of course there is also
you know if if
Republican anywhere you know a state
legislator you have never heard of says
something boneheaded or offensive about
a racial group that person is guaranteed
national stardom I want to ask what you
think we can do with regard to as
conservatives to reach out to minority
voters so you talk about putting people
in communities to to talk about these
politics not taking voters for granted
yeah this is one area where as I stated
up front I'm very concerned about
president Trump's administration because
Trump himself is so apt to say just the
wrong kind of thing that I think it's
very likely that he is alienated a huge
number of people in growing minority
groups and and I include among that you
know single women and and married women
in the suburbs there there are a number
of different groups that he seems to be
alienating almost systematically in a
fashion that that won't be good for him
electoral and won't be good for the
Republican Party long term you know I
lived my entire life in California I
look at the the voting constituency of
Hispanics and Latinos in California and
they vote 8020 Democrat maybe maybe
higher than that and then you go to
Texas and it looks a lot more like 55 45
Democrat and that is because of the
different different attitudes I would
fit I would think of the California
Republican Party toward immigration and
toward Hispanics generally as opposed to
the Texas attitude toward immigration
and toward Hispanics generally and I
wonder if the Republican Party is moving
too much in the direction of California
and less in the direction of Texas well
I'm not a fan of the way present Trump
talks about racial issues in general he
has however speaking of somebody's often
criticized him on this front he has made
some efforts to try to appeal to
Hispanic voters and african-american
voters and I think there is an element
of the change that Trump is wrought in
the Republican Party that could be
useful here because one of the reasons
why Republicans have not tended to do
well among african-americans and
Hispanics and frankly among young people
is that Republicans and conservatives
have been seen as people who are most
interested almost exclusively interested
in the economic interests of big
business and rich people and that hurts
I think Republicans across the board but
it's particularly going to hurt you with
demographic groups that are having a
harder time
getting jobs having a harder time
affording health insurance and so forth
and that is true of African Americans
it's true of Hispanics it's true of
young people single people let's talk
about that for a second so you've
written about reform conservatism I
passed the idea that conservatism ought
to embrace more government involvement
in a lot of economic areas I tend to be
a lot more libertarian and and less
comfortable with those sorts of
conversations simply because the
slippery slope is so incredibly slippery
as far as government involvement in
these particular issues so where do you
think that the government should be
involved right in issues like for
example health care or in the job market
or in dealing with big business so I
don't think of reform conservatism as
being about we need more government I
think it's about we need to apply
conservative insights to the problems of
today as opposed to the problems of 1981
so what I want on health care is a
radically reduced federal rule where
there's much less regulation and where
federal spending federal tax and federal
regulation does a lot less to channel
where money is going in this sector and
I'd say the same thing about higher
education as well what I think has been
a problem is that there has been a
tendency on the part of conservatives
because the Reagan's formula was so
successful
to just stick with it and think well
let's just keep cutting marginal tax
rates and act as though there's still 70
percents
the way they were in 1981 now do I
believe that we should just radically
privatize health care and get rid of
Medicare and Medicaid you know let's get
a couple more realistic items on the
agenda done and then we can we can talk
about that I'm not sure I'm not sure if
I were starting from scratch I would
create these programs in the first place
or Social Security but they are here and
I think there's a lot that conservatives
could do usefully to change these things
and make them more more conducive to
success in a country that is mostly
decentralized mostly about trial and
error and markets these are systems like
Medicare and Medicaid higher education
think we're not created by conservatives
in general and we can't
I think adopt the posture that either
we've got
them all up or we just kind of go look
at something else
right we just do taxes all the time and
that I think is the mindset that that
reformed conservatives had to sort of
overthrow what do you think the
conservative movement should do about
big business so there is this this open
debate over whether big business is
something that conservative should be
for or against it's always appeared to
me that using big business as a separate
class is a very bizarre sort of
distinction because what makes a
business worse or better doesn't depend
on the size of the business it depends
on the sort of activities it's
undertaking and its relationship with
the government but there is this this
attitude that has become very popular
I'm left with folks like Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders and then on
the right with Tucker Carlson the big
business is inherently bad business and
thus the government should step in to
break up companies the one we hear most
about these days is Facebook we heard a
lot about the big tech companies what's
your take on the role of government in
in dealing with a lot of these big tech
companies well so amid business in
general I would say that we've got a
large range of government subsidies for
big businesses that I think that we
should get rid of or at least scale back
because I'm Pro market before I'm
pro-business and pro big business I
don't think that Americans are looking
for the candidate I think this is a
great populist mistake they're not
looking for the person who will be the
scourge of big business or the scourge
of Wall Street's and they shouldn't be I
do think that they want somebody who
understands that most people have
different interests than big business
and Wall Street and you know that
they're looking out for them and
sometimes there will be things that
public policymakers can do that help big
business and Wall Street and the average
Joe and sometimes there are places where
you have to make a choice and they want
to come out ahead and that choice I just
think the public is a lot more sensible
sometimes than we give them credit for
on the specific questions about big tech
I think there's just it's it's a
complicated issue frankly there are a
range of questions that people bring up
so there's the privacy question for
example with respect to Facebook and so
forth and I tend to think frankly that
that's overrated
I think people talk a good game about
privacy but they don't actually through
their revealed preferences show that
they care much about privacy at all
so Facebook
for example if you were if Facebook
offered a sort of privacy protective
package where you could be a you could
be part of Facebook and it would be ten
bucks a month there be I think
essentially zero uptake to that and in
fact to make it clear market wise would
probably have to be more like five
hundred dollars fee but I think that
there are some important questions about
what it's doing to our social landscape
what it's doing to our kids some of that
a lot of that 80% of that has to be
addressed by parents but there's also
questions of policy and you know one
thing that I think we should look at is
the way our schools have incorporated
technology I think that a lot of that
there's been kind of techno philia that
is kind of crazy I'm not saying we
should have they should all be using an
abacus but so so I guess what I'm saying
is we need to think through specific
problems and solutions to them rather
than sort of having a sort of a
generalized attitude toward the tech
companies and basing everything on that
so talked about a couple of areas of
that Reagan stool that we talked about
early we've talked about the social
conservative side I don't talk a little
bit more about that now so the pro-life
movement obviously has become
extraordinarily powerful inside the
right side of the islands how the
conservative movement I'm very happy
about that I do wonder whether the
tactics that are being pursued by state
republican parties are are beneficial to
the long-term goals of the pro-life
movement so for example the state of
georgia passing heartbeat bills the the
attempt to pass protection from
conception bills before the supreme
court has even weighed in on incremental
changes to roe v wade it seems like this
might be tempting fate this is actually
maybe throwing good policy in the teeth
of the supreme court that is likely to
strike it down what do you think is the
best tactic for conservatives to use in
fighting that pro-life battle well I
think that over the last twenty years or
so twenty to thirty years really we have
seen three things simultaneously we have
seen states passing restrictions on
abortion we have seen people being more
willing to identify themselves as
pro-life rather than pro-choice and
and we have seen a reduction in the
number and rate of abortions seems to me
that that's not a coincidence that these
three things have worked in tandem so
the incrementalist strategy which really
starts with the campaign in the mid-90s
against partial birth abortion I think
has been successful now I completely
sympathize with my fellow pro lifers who
are impatient and who say you know this
the numbers are not going down as fast
and as far as we should want them to
there that's absolutely right but I do
think we have to be careful and what we
owe unborn children is not just
statements of support but practical and
effective action that will achieve our
goals of getting laws that recognize
their humanity and their right to life
and getting practices that welcome them
into life I am concerned that some of
these laws that are being passed at
different states like Georgia make it
harder for us to win our cases at the
Supreme Court and may also make it
harder for us to get politically
sustainable protection for unborn
children at the same time though we've
got a left that is going so far to the
extreme on their own I think would be
better positioned to capitalize on that
if we were a little if if we sort of
gestured let's say toward the publics
ambivalence about abortion without
necessarily totally embracing that
ambivalence if our public stance was
something look we want every child
protected in in law and in life but in
the meantime can we at least agree on
the third trimester and try to bring
some of those soft pro-choice folks over
to our side and then once we've got that
social consensus once we've built and
codified that then we can say okay how
about a week before the third trimester
is there anything really that's so
different about unborn children at this
stage of development that they don't
deserve protection and sort of working
to persuade people in a way that's you
know sort of course part of what's going
on here Ben is that this work in court
made it seem like persuasion wasn't
necessary that you could just accomplish
what you need to by Fiat and part of
what Georgia and Alabama
these other states are doing it's not
serious legislating in the sense that
they don't think this law is going to
take effect it's a statement to the
Supreme Court it's a it's a throwing
down of the gauntlet and I suspect if we
remove to actual legislation we might
see the potential to build a consensus
for life
so we've talked about a couple of the
legs the third leg of the stool when the
Regan's tool is the hawkish foreign
policy and here we've seen a lot of fire
fighting inside the Republican Party of
late John Bolton being ousted from the
Trump administration Rand Paul is Cheney
going at it over American foreign policy
what do you think if is is there any
consensus among Republicans or
conservatives on foreign policy it seems
to me like this may be the weakest leg
of the Republican stool at this point
mainly because it's not top priority
until it's top priority for the house
that's right it's never the thing that
anybody cares about until we get attack
god forbid or until a war breaks out but
with that said there was a general
consensus after 9/11 that the United
States needed to take a muscular role in
the world to prevent the bad guys from
coming here and that consensus seems to
be breaking down contributed to in large
part by President Trump who I'm old
enough to remember when Republicans
spent eight years defending george w
bush from accusations that he was war
criminal and then donald trump ran on
the platform that george w bush was war
criminal in 2016 won the nomination and
then won the presidency so do you think
that there is any sort of consensus
inside the republican party on the
foreign policy front well you know the
debate between Elizabeth Cheney and Rand
Paul I think it's a depressing
illustration of the point we were
talking about earlier where everything
ends up being about Trump they're
talking about these most important
questions of what the federal government
should do what's our role in the world
be war peace and it's become who likes
president Trump better right that's what
it's just a performative I mean it's all
this all King Lear ever everything with
President Trump is King Lear like Ken
Cordelia finally appeal to him and earn
a share of the kingdom not like a junior
high version last week but so sometimes
you're talking to people who are really
interested in foreign policy and they'll
ask during the Q&A when or American
voters gonna make this a top issues like
you don't want the American voters to
make foreign policy topics you because
it's a sign that something's gone really
badly wrong if that happens what
Americans expect the P
in charge of government to be taking
care of that set of issues and they'll
they don't want to think about it all
that much themselves they don't know
frankly a lot of stuff about what's
going on in different international hot
spots but if something flares up they'll
get they'll be upset that these things
were not taken care of
I'd myself tend towards a kind of
pragmatism in foreign policy where I
think our foreign policy has to be
hard-headed based on the pursuit of
American national interests and that
means it can't be isolationist we can't
pretend as though we are you know 1875
America but at the same time we can't be
the leaders of a global crusade for
liberal democracy because our resources
are limited and we are not omnipotent
there is a huge space in between those
visions but it does seem as though the
debate is largely conducted between
those visions but the other thing I
would say is regardless of sort of where
you draw the line where we should be you
do want a foreign policy that is steady
that is competently executed that our
allies and enemies both have a general
sense of where we're coming from and and
I would give low marks to this
administration on that question so now I
want to ask you to do what our friend
Jonah Goldberg or to call rank pundit
race I want I want you to evaluate the
Democratic field going into the
primaries for next year now if you were
to do an overall assessment of the
Democratic field where are the strengths
among these candidates in the primaries
and where do you see the the possibility
of victory over President Trump in a
general so my rank pundits card may have
been revoked in 2016 when I for all I
lost too much money in 2016 to ever do
it again it seems to me that sort of the
theory of Biden makes more sense than
the actual Biden but a somebody who is
not for kicking everybody an
employer-based health insurance or
Medicare Advantage off of the plans that
they have and in general like you know
who doesn't believe that
deportation is always a dirty word when
it comes to illegal immigrants but you
know you have there are real questions
about whether he's up to it whether he's
up to the presidency or whether he's up
to being the nominee and even the
Democrats who say well okay so sometimes
he says dumb things but he's up against
Trump yeah but you're you are losing the
opportunity to capitalize on a potential
strength against Trump if you run him
I've been in the BI camp with Biden I
still think that's true and it's partly
because let's turn to I who I think is
his number-one rival for the Democrats
at this point that's Elizabeth Warren
and partly with Elizabeth Warren I think
she is a classic so the old theory of
the Democratic nomination process was
there's a beer track and a wine track
and and the beer track voters are people
who are much more sort of kind of like
the old the old hard hat Democrats and
very practical minded often socially
conservative or socially moderate the
kind of people who who propelled
Mondale's win over Gary Hart who was a
wine track candidate or Gore's over Bill
Bradley and the the big normally the
beer track candidate wins the Democratic
nomination the great difference was 2008
when african-americans who are typically
with the beer track candidate sided with
Obama and you had a coalition of
affluent socially liberal whites and
african-americans and that's the
majority in the Democratic primary
Warren right now has part of that
coalition she's got the affluent
socially liberal whites she doesn't yet
have any demonstrated appeal to African
American voters I have a hard time
seeing how she wins the nomination
without making some inroads there so I I
just think her demographic base is too
narrow there's Bernie Sanders
I think Sanders misunderstood the 2016
race and a lot of Sanders supporters
misunderstood the 2016 race they thought
that people were supporting him because
he's a socialist and in fact he was he
did more to help socialism than
socialism did to help him and being a
socialist meant that he was crazy enough
to challenge Hillary Clinton
when everybody else with any ambition in
the party was was swept off the field
but there was an anti Clinton market
there were people who didn't like her
people who thought she was cynical and
corrupt who knows where they got that
idea and they liked him because he was
idealistic but when he's not up against
Hillary Clinton and when there are
several people in the race his market
turns out to be much smaller than that
and I think he's sinking and I think
he's gonna continue to sink as a result
finally there are the sort of the
moderate non Biden folks sort of like
the clover chars maybe the Booker's
based on his past if not where he is
right now and I think that we've reached
a stage in the primary you know all of
those guys boo to judge another one
they're all assuming that if Biden
collapses they'll be there to inherit it
I don't think that's the way it's gonna
work I think of Biden collapses
Democratic elites will say well I guess
there is no audience for moderation and
you know it's it's full speed ahead and
it'll it'll work to the advantage of one
of the other candidates so let's talk
for a second about the rise of the woke
white progressives there been a bunch of
studies that have come out recently that
show that the most liberal folks in the
party the most leftist folks in the
party are no longer members of racial
minorities that's not actually what's
driving a lot of the feeling on sort of
the woke side the Howard Zinn a'f
occation of the Democratic Party instead
it's a bunch of people who went to prep
schools and colleges on the coasts and
they are way to the left of the general
population what happened to the
Democratic Party that the woke the woke
white left took it over because it used
to be that the most left-leaning area of
the Democratic Party in a lot of ways
was not that particular demographic now
it's college-educated whites who are
leading the charge directly off that
left-wing cliff so I think it's a lot of
things have fed into this one is
polarization and the old conservative
Democrats having left the party and old
liberal Republicans joining the
Democratic Party it's partly thinking
that you know history is on their side
and misunderstandings of what happened
in 2016 so if it's the Russians fault or
if it's just Hillary didn't go to
Wisconsin or Hillary was a personally
off-putting candidate even then you
don't need to make any compromises on
your positions there's nothing wrong
with your old
program so you got all of those things
going for then there's this sort of the
emotional reaction to Trump's oh so you
become sort of more hostile to any
position that is associated with Trump
and associated with the Republican Party
and then finally I do believe that
social media has played a role here that
but people are in the echo chamber of of
Twitter where the woke white left looms
larger and that affects how they think
about where the party is where that it
changes the way journalists think we're
the center of the Democratic Party is
for example and it's wildly
unrepresentative of most voters it's not
just a question of views being different
it's also a question of the things that
are on people's minds being different if
you are a Twitter obsessive as I I'll
confess sometimes I am compared to
normal people and you know we get a
misleading picture of Democrats we think
that your typical Democratic voter is
obsessed with what pronouns people use
and this is not true yeah and I think
that really is the the social media
bubble that you're talking about I think
that it's it may have started with the
sort of get out white vote meaning the
the movie get out have features this
this white couple who is obviously too
stained but they spend their time
talking to the black main character
about how they voted for Barack Obama
and this has alleviated them of all of
their white guilt over everything it's
the group of folks were taking pictures
of themselves in the ballot box while
they are in the voting booth while they
were voting for Barack Obama and now
social media has has generated an entire
cottage industry of all this Aziz Ansari
has a comedy special in which he talks
about the white liberals who are sitting
there doing their virtue signaling
points talking about how they love crazy
rich Asians even if they only kind of
like crazy rich Asians to demonstrate to
everybody else how how woke they are and
it seems unsustainable because that side
of the party is still a minority of the
Democratic Party I mean by polling data
the Joe Biden wing of the party is still
larger than the white woke liberal
strain of the Democratic Party I wonder
if at any point there are enough members
of the Democratic Party to just shout
stop this is going too far
well you know there's a history for that
so if you think back to 1992 or the lady
when you have Bill Clinton trying to
change the Democratic Party think about
his three great heresies in the 92
campaign for the left it was welfare
reform the death penalty and and if you
remember sister souljah you may have
been too young for that but you know
blacks actually kill white people that
was those were all views that were
actually come widely shared among
Democratic voters but offended a thin
slice of democratic activists and
opinion leaders and and Clinton was able
to to make a huge change in the party by
leveraging that fact he's got the
country at large to change its opinion
of Democrats at least for a while and it
was acceptable to Democrats at large
because this group of people were not
actually representative them so maybe
that happens again but of course that
required three losses in presidential
elections in a row before Democrats were
willing to take that medicine and and
the elites were willing to say maybe
some of the things we've been doing need
to change it also feels like the level
of interconnection has made this so much
more difficult because before if you had
nuts who were kind of screaming at you
you just said okay there are few nuts
who are screaming at me now you have
crazy people screaming at you and entire
corporations bow before them and Kevin
Williamson in his new book talks
specifically about the activation of the
corporation as a tool of the left in the
sense that corporations are created to
create the company man they create the
company man that sort of the widgets who
work for them and they have to have
corporate positions on everything and
they are there to to avoid risk and the
greatest risk for a lot of companies
right now is being in the headlines at
all so if you see 12 tweets about
something then you better issue an
apology and move to the left and and in
signal about how much you you love
particular aspects of the social Left
program simply to avoid all of the
blowback so I wonder in the area of
social media if it's ever gonna be
possible to walk this stuff back because
the loudest people tend to have outsized
impact on social media and because
companies don't seem to have the
willingness in the corporate world to
actually just say no to all of this
nonsense I mean do you see that there's
going to be any sort of corporate
blowback coming or is the entire market
going to fragment right now because
putting aside government it seems like
on a social level what we are now aiming
toward is completely different spheres
in which we all operate like
conservatives won't be able to go to
Walmart anymore they'll go to
conservative Walmart and liberals will
only be able to go to I remember one
wrong exactly right I mean well I think
it is still the case I think it just
long been the case and is still the case
that conservatives are more sort of
quiet istic about a lot of these things
and are more likely to compartmentalize
politics from other things so yeah
they're you know when Nike threw Betsy
Ross under the bus there were definitely
conservative said well I'm not buying
Nike anymore but I think it is still the
case that your average conservative is
more likely to say well it's a good -
I'm gonna buy it
now that may change and that may be
changing now but until at least recently
I think you'd have to say that it made
sense for companies to be more
responsive to the left than to the right
based on this behavioural difference
between conservatives and liberals
okay so President Trump has
extraordinarily high approval ratings
among Republicans not among Americans
generally but among Republicans and
you've talked about polarization you've
talked about the fact that the left is
polarized and that the right is
polarized is the is it wise for the
Democratic Party to continue to fight
these cultural wars they continue to
believe that they are winning the
culture wars but it seems like for every
culture war they win they lose a
political war because conservatives
don't know how to fight culture war so
instead they fight culture wars by
electing culture warriors to positions
of political prominence well it depends
on your priorities I mean if you are a
liberal activist who's mainly interested
in those culture Wars then ya go on
finding them and you know you have made
gains and you may continue to make gains
if you're most concerned about you know
getting more getting a higher minimum
wage you're getting more government
provided health care or something maybe
that doesn't make sense as your priority
because I do think that it gets in the
way of building a larger Democratic
coalition I mean my free advice since I
don't think it'll be actually taking up
to Democrats if I were them the message
I would use against Trump in 2020
leaving aside what shape the economy is
in would be something like he's
plutocratic he's got you know he talks
about being on the side of the
workers and he's got all these Goldman
Sachs people in his administration on
all these lobbyists and he you know he's
not actually interested in in the con
but that I think would require a level
of discipline that they're not capable
of attaining because what actually moves
them is more you know what pronouns
people easily and the other thing is you
know so think about these Obama Trump
think about a Wisconsin there was
calories in Wisconsin that voted for
Bush twice and Obama twice and in Trump
that voted for Scott Walker and then
voted for Tammy Baldwin
these people are not locked in they
absolutely a segment of them at least
could be courted back to the Democratic
Party but does it seem to you that the
Democratic Party is more interested in
courting those voters or in judging them
and trying to get to tell them you know
you should be ashamed of yourself for
the way you voted last time it seems to
me there's an obvious answer that
question and it seems to me that those
voters know look the answer that
question as well and do you think that
that attitude is extended to the
intelligencia inside the Democratic
Party so you live in LA you live in New
York I'm sure you've had many long
conversations with folks on the Left
over the years I get the feeling because
you live in the DC area so okay sorry
yeah exactly yeah but when it comes to
these sort of pun autocracy it feels
like it's it's more and more difficult
to find people on the other side of the
aisle who are even willing to have the
conversation in fact the the willingness
to have a conversation is seen as a sort
of heresy
among certain members of the the
intelligentsia on the left step in your
experience oh there's no question that
that that happens remember Joel Kaplan
getting by some Facebook
employees because he showed up during
the hearings for his friend Brett
Kavanaugh when and former colleague for
the Supreme Court so yeah it's all
people are people are not willing to
concede that intelligent people of
goodwill can be on the other side of
them from an issue at least when they're
not thinking about people they already
know and alike so maybe they're willing
to make that concession about a family
member or about a friend but it's very
easy to think of a kind of faceless
abstraction of conservatives or liberals
and they're all terrible people and so
it's a huge problem and frankly even on
the friends and fam
partly because of polarization people
have less of that in their own lives and
they used to do you think that's fixable
my belief is that the the militating
social institutions that used to at
least allow us to get together and see
each other face to face and not see just
our political perspectives on Facebook
have fallen away into the growth of
social media coincident with the
destruction of the social fabric have
have mounted to what may be an
unbridgeable gap do you believe that
this is restorable so I I think that the
social issues from the nationalization
of the social issues did a lot to
unleash this dynamic it has sort of
floated free to some extent and and
taken on a life of its own
but again outside of Twitter most people
are not quite that revved up and I do
think and maybe this is sort of utopian
on my part I do think that if you were
to D nationalize some of those issues
that maybe politics could move to a
healthier place but but at the moment
it's very hard to see it at the moment
you can just see the way this dynamic
just feeds on itself over and over so
from a conservative perspective we've
talked about sort of how to defend
relies these issues if you're on the
Left namely concede that abortion is not
a national Supreme Court issue but if
you're on the right how would you go
about see federalizing a lot of these
issues when it looks as though you're
battling people who want to keep
federalizing all of these issues well
it's in a way it's sort of easier advice
for us because we just have to win v
wade and we've never really you know so
I suppose you could say there was an
attempt in the and in the 2000s to have
a federal solution on same-sex marriage
but certainly nobody on the conservative
side of that issue still thinks that
that is the thing to do at most and this
is probably too far reach its wanting to
recreate federalism on that issue and I
do think that that has to be what we
allow because we're just not going to
build a national consensus on each of
these issues how do we get back to an
educational an educational role for for
the Intelligencia and and get back to
education in sort of the basics because
everybody has an opinion on abortion
everybody has an opinion on same-sex
marriage nobody seems to understand how
checks and balances work including the
presidential candidates who seem to
spend each and every day promising
they are going to override every single
check and balance in the Constitution to
do whatever it is that they want to do
today beta rock promising that he's
simply going to come to your house
personally and take your guns for
example or Elizabeth Warren suggesting
she's going to personally rewrite the
First Amendment is there a way to
re-educate people about the importance
of these institutions or if people
basically given up on that because again
it's a lot easier to sound off on the
issues than it is to understand that
sometimes checks and balances meet and
you don't get what you want so I think
partly it has to be a way and I don't
I'm not gonna be able to answer a
follow-up question but we have to figure
out a way to reward legislators for
being legislators so so much of what
folks in what ought to be the first
branch of the federal government do is
they use their position as a platform
for self expression frankly president
Trump does a lot of this too I mean he
he views himself sometimes as the
internet commoner in chief rather than
the president the United States Donny
from right so what goes against the
grain of our culture over the last 50
years is we need people who are more
willing to take up the institutional
role and maybe a little less eager to
express themselves personally and our
culture is all about self expression
right it is not at all about self
control and that gets worse year after
year so in a way I mean I've just like
sort of maybe identified one of the
preconditions for solving the problem
just not quite the same thing as solving
the problem maybe the answer to that is
that the American people need to stop
looking to politicians as their moral
guides it's always been very well truth
is useful in that respect I mean I've
actually said this to Matt to my friends
on the left is you guys keep bitching
about Trump and believe me I didn't like
Barack Obama very much you know I have a
solution for this is that the executive
branch could just become most powerful
and then you wouldn't care who is the
head of the executive branch and I feel
the same way about the federal
government generally we spend such an
enormous amount of time trying to
struggle with the ramifications of a
powerful federal government well if you
don't like who's running it and I don't
like who's running it then how about we
just minimized the power of this of this
giant institution first place so let me
say something nice about the public I do
think that if they say let's say Biden
were the nominee if he were to run a
campaign one of whose most important
implicit messages at least is look make
me president and you won't hear from me
every day you know there will not be
drama cost
I will not share with you my opinion
about Don Lemon I think that there'd be
a big audience for that for people who
frankly I think that was part of george
w bush's campaign message in 2000 which
was like i'm not gonna actually disrupt
all this the the clinton status quo but
i'll you know they'll be dignity you
won't be sort of averting your eyes from
the oval office the way you had to under
the under bill clinton and i think that
that is something that people still
would like I totally agree with this I
mean I have the the bizarre opinion that
Joe Biden's apparent narcolepsy as well
as his shocking senility may actually
cut in favor of him in a general
election because who's scared of that
guy right I mean like he's going to
early bird dinner to Denny's he don't
have to worry about that guy being a
transformational president and rewriting
the rules of the road or shocking us all
out of our complacency he's just gonna
be some guy right he's he could bring
back the fireside chat you know it's a
completely plot I mean he'd be
distributing record players like I'm
totally into this like as long as he's
into the the record player business and
not in our face like I'm not voting for
Joe Biden but the fact is that that is
an appealing idea that the we are not in
this fight every single day when one
second I want to ask Ramesh whether he
actually is going to vote for Donald
Trump the hardest question of all
Ramesh of course visiting fellow at the
American Enterprise Institute if you
want to hear Ramesh's final answer you
have to subscribe over a daily wire comm
go there click Subscribe make the magic
happen for yourself
Ramesh Ponnuru thanks so much for
stopping by this has really been a joy
thanks for your time
you're welcome this is fun
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
directed by Mathis Glover and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy Boren associate producer Colton
Haas our guests are booked by Kaitlyn
Maynard post-production is supervised by
Alex Singaram editing by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
title graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
[Music]